this past weekend the 10th international
came to a close that's right you heard
me 10th and if you're like me and you've
watched all 10 of these summits live
then i'm sure you can agree that this
one was for the ages from the stomps to
the skewers to the fact that the team to
take home nearly 20 million dollars was
spirit
it's safe to say that the 10th annual be
all and end all of dota 2 or as i like
to call it the best two weeks in esports
was a certified banger
let's get into it
[Music]
okay before we start diving fools and
skewering them out from under their tier
threes i must ask that all of you
beautiful talented gigabrained men and
women who stan and support dota like the
video subscribe to the channel and turn
on notifications
appreciate you okay so after two
t-i-less years filled with dread misery
and way too much online play esports
finally got back its best tournament
and boy
was it a heater we had hassan bol the
boyar tour farmed a bunch but
unfortunately for us eg diehards didn't
win og were looking like they might
dazzle yet again but thankfully didn't
repeat
and the roster to take home the lion's
share of nearly 40 million us dollars
was team secret spirit spirit
sorry i just still can't process the
fact that the other team something writ
didn't win now if you don't follow dota
especially closely team spirit being
crowned ti champions might come as
something of a surprise if you do follow
it closely
it might come as even more of a surprise
so who are team spirit
well they're a fresh new largely
inexperienced group of cis-born
nobodies i don't mean that in a mean way
i don't i mean they're literally a group
of up-and-coming miposhka-led rookies
who'd never even been to ti before
and they won the damn thing because as
we all know ti isn't real life it's just
anime incarnates for two weeks the laws
of reality get suspended and dota
becomes this harrowing scripted soap
opera where dreams come true so long as
they should have been impossible to
begin with it is the best thing in
esports
no cap as the kids say what makes this
whole thing even crazier is that they
did it from the second round of the
lower bracket the only team ever to do
that before was team liquid in 2017 and
let me tell you they were way bigger
contenders than spirit and that is not
even touching upon who spirit beat you
know that grim reaper meme the one with
the logos on the doors this was that on
like steroids they started out by
beating fanatic which was like oh nice
and then they proceeded to oh you know
2-0
oh gee handing the two-time back-to-back
champions their first main stage loss in
four years
and can i just say on behalf of all of
us
thank
[ __ ] god team spirits
end the game taking down oh gee
what a cinderella story here on the main
stage absolutely incredible team spirit
and look at them they're cold there's
this cool stone in there
they just knocked out the chance now to
be very clear i have nothing against og
i love og i was in vancouver when they
made their ti8 anime success story and
it will forever be the greatest thing to
ever happen in esports
but if they had won a third consecutive
ti
like
dota would just have been over like
gaben would have had to delete it from
steam spirit went on to roll vertice pro
invictus gaming and make top three
before toppling western tournament
favorites and all-around super team
secret in the lower bracket final before
facing off against eastern tournament
favorites and all-around super team psg
lgd in the grand final and what a
[ __ ] final it was i mean
come on now if for some reason you
didn't catch it either because you can't
follow dota to save your life or because
you're some league weirdo who was
watching week 86 of worlds here is the
gist of it psg lgd are guaranteed to win
there's like no shot they lose it's
pretty much impossible their star player
ame gets paid more than most teams in
fact by upsetting secret spirit have
basically handed china their first ti in
half a decade so naturally spirit went
up to nothing
because
again
it's ti also because apparently collapse
is the new son of magnus and since lgd
opted not to ban it they were forced to
watch as the homie blinks skewered their
goods into the loving bosom of
collapse's teammates every chance he got
it was truly a master class in magnus s4
would be proud the spider leg walking in
they get him with the horn toss chase
him down for more amaze done
remember when xiao 8 was all oh we know
about the magnus we got this
one
[Music]
how'd that go for you bud but they catch
him right away with the cliff collapse
pulls him back in breaks the coil
they're thinking about going they pull
him back in and he is done there's an
opening the horn toss the pullback with
skewer and immediately gets the kill i
know i know they countered it with the
rubik i'm just i'm just meaning is it
copium to say like shin q did that it
had nothing to do with why lgd lost
i mean kind of
should they have banned it in game five
maybe but hey they did put on one hell
of a performance oh and if you haven't
done yourself the favor of watching the
russian vod of spirit going up 2-0
you really should it's a tree some
goated reddit user put together a
translation and it is the hypest thing i
have ever seen havost is
stupefied as v lot puts on the
performance of a lifetime
[Music]
of course spirit proceeded to get
absolutely rocked in the next two games
because
again
it's ti wise not die and nobody's dying
they already fall again as gg has called
23-3
a statement from lgd
did he get a blank call
it didn't happen
it was just too cool that was crazy
the result was a game five that spirit
had no business being in never mind
winning one that will definitely go down
in history as one of the greats since at
this point pretty much everyone figured
that spirit's mental was chalked beyond
repair especially
after this happened eight seconds until
i'm over the engine they're looking to
close it up
they contain somebody with the battery
protection
protection is it it's not over yet it's
not over yet but it wasn't somehow
because again
say it with me this time
it's
ti they're gonna chase on slight chase
he's gone
two minutes
ancient exposed they're ready to close
it this time
only two left
can they stop at psg lgbt they can't
give god
[Applause]
but the game five
even though they get knocked out in
three or four spirit
they come back with the same
skill and ability that's taking them to
this whole road
is this the craziest cinderella story in
the history of the international crazier
than og at ti-8
i mean it has to be right like don't get
me wrong og were down bad back then but
they'd still won majors once upon a time
plus og traversed through the upper
bracket
spirit's run through the lower
was an anime power-up for the ages or
better yet
aegis
oh come on
that was good
that said it is nice to see a sort of
ember spirit-esque balance and all
things regularity instilled back within
the international i have long said that
the only reason i didn't like watching
og win ti9 was because i was a huge fan
of that insane no repeat winner record
that we had the international has always
been about
forever changing five players lives and
i'm super glad that this year we got
that back in droves of course there's
other stuff to talk about as well hassan
bowl eg going out early secret failing
to close yet again and the myriad of
roster shuffles that are guaranteed to
start leaking in the weeks to come
nothing helps cure post ti withdrawal
like some good old-fashioned drama
where are you at lgd ame fan i'm dying
out here come on we need you also shout
out to the insane talent lineup a lot of
first-timers this year and y'all were
phenomenal i've been watching this game
for
a long long time and it was extremely
refreshing to see the vets complimented
by a sea of fresh passionate
personalities anyway that's all i got
for you today all in all ti 10
certified heater totally worth the wait
of course now all we can do is sit
around hop into a ti 11 waiting room
thread on reddit and
talk [ __ ] about all the awful magnus
pickers in our pubs
see you next time
it's just like it would literally be the
equivalent of you know that cloud9 team
the 2018 worlds one with like blabber
and licorice and like with the benching
and all that [ __ ] if they had won 2018
worlds and then 2019 worlds
you'd be looking at it like okay this is
cool but like what the [ __ ] is going on
like this is not real life like this is
that's that is literally og
thompson was this little fresh sweet
little pub star who won ti it was his
first lan he'd never played a land
before and he won ti and people were
like it's magical it's anime it's anime
by the power of god and anime this man
did it it's awesome it's great and then
a year later did it again and people
were just like
dan rosen has said that for years he
says that if og wins had won this third
consecutive ti gaben would walk out on
stage and he would just announce the
dota is over like it's been beaten it's
been solved